it's a strange way to run an election
take a not particularly representative
State overwhelmingly white Rural and
heavily religious then during the
coldest and most inhospitable time of
year let it winnow down the candidates
for the most powerful job in the world
they can throw a blizzard at us in the
Iowa caucuses on Monday Republicans are
casting the first votes to be counted in
the 2024 presidential primary campaign
we're leading massively in Iowa Donald
Trump a 77-year-old former president who
was voted out of office has a runaway
lead in the polls I want a big win
they've talked as high as 40% I would be
delighted if it was a 40% win for Trump
so all the sporting interest is in the
battle for second place with Florida
Governor Ronda santis and former South
Carolina Governor Nikki Haley sparring
for the right to be the alternative to
Trump presumably the top three vote
Getters are the Republicans uh um Trum
dandis and Haley and whatever second or
third place order that happens to be
that's what's going to happen I think
that much has sped in Haley hopes
winning silver in Iowa will Mark the end
of dtis campaign great
again SFA fund Inc is responsible for
the content of
this the weather has a vote in this
election temperatures are expected to
dip to
-28° C that would make these the coldest
Iowa con uses ever forecasters are
calling it frostbite conditions that
could seriously depress turnout and mean
only the hardiest voters decide who
wins one major committed group in Iowa
Evangelical Christians some are looking
for an alternative but despite Trump's
three divorces two impeachments and 91
criminal charges many of them like him a
lot of evangelicals have support for
Trump that you just can't strip away
because they see the things that are
happening to him they think he's being
persecuted they see him as a martyr with
little suspense about who's likely to
win in Iowa the campaign's focus now is
largely on beating expectations if
you're the top dog and you're supposed
to like cream the competition and you
kind of sorted to but not quite oddly
enough that can be a defeat meeting or
falling short of those expectations can
determine who has momentum as the race
moves on to other states John hendin
alzer de Mo
Iowa make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer